so with the impending release of God of
War three remastered on the ps4 we
thought we'd take a look at all three
mainline god of war games and compare
their openings all three are epic in
some way or another we thought we'd take
a look and see which one we think is
most epic first up God of War one its
memorable in its own way you fight the
Hydra as you move through the various
stages on boat and beyond not only does
the Hydra fight use god of war signature
QuickTime events but you also get the
chance to use traversal to your benefits
each time you face the Hydra the game is
a lot of fun very bombastic very big in
general it's the bits in between that
bring the opening down just a little in
some cases that means walking on narrow
beams in another case this means pushing
a crate around so that you can get to
higher ground
all well archers Pelt you with arrows
it's telling that by the time God of War
three comes around there is no more
walking around on narrow beams and even
in the case of God of War 2 the puzzles
during the opening sequence are a lot
more interesting than that stupid crate
pushing 1 all-in-all God of War Ones
opening is excellent and of course epic
however it is one upped by the two that
were to come later God of War two one
ups the original in almost every way
this is a fight against the great
Colossus of Rhodes and it is also of the
three openings for the main line games
the longest all in all this fight
remains very focused the Colossus of
Rhodes attacks you as you move from one
part of the level to the next and it
concludes with you actually entering the
Colossus of Rhodes and scaling his
innards so that you can finally bring
him down
the platforming sequence that closes
this opening may not be as epic as
climbing Gaia in God of War 3 but it's
certainly an interesting ending and
brings a lot more variety than just the
hacking and slashing and the QuickTime
events that came before if you were to
say that God of War two's opening was
the best of the three I don't know that
I would argue greatly with you on the
face of it God of War threes opening is
the opening to end all openings in this
case you're facing Poseidon multiple
times as you climb Gaia there are many
many moving parts to this level and
what's most interesting about it is that
Gaia keeps changing positions as you
fight Poseidon there are lots of games
in which you do battle on moving parts
and pieces but there's nothing quite as
stupendous as this God of War three
opening in which you go from climbing
Gaia to doing battle two QuickTime
events with Poseidon and so on and so
forth if there's a downside it's that
it's actually over fairly quickly at
least when you compare it to God of War
two's Colossus of Rhodes opening the
other downside might be that God of War
three opens so strongly that there isn't
a whole lot left to come that can really
stand up to that level of excellence in
their contexts I would probably argue
that God of War two's opening is
actually the stronger one however on its
own God of War three's introduction is
so incredible that it still stands as
one of the series high points when it
comes to God of War which opening do you
like the best
leave your vote in the comments below
you